parliament backed a 1.2 billion euro
package to help support ukraine's
economy meps also debated ways to
de-escalate tensions between russia and
ukraine and political group leaders
released a statement in support of kiev
parliament president roberta metzola
called on the commission to apply the
conditionality mechanism linking eu
funds to respect of the rule of law the
call came after the ecj rejected the
legal challenge of two eu member states
hungary and poland
meps called for a committee of inquiry
into the use of pegasus spyware in the
eu and elsewhere activists journalists
and lawyers featured on a list of more
than 50 000 phone numbers around the
world thought to have been targeted by
the malware
each year 1.3 million people die from
cancer in the eu
meps from the beating cancer special
committee presented their proposals
including how to better tackle risk
factors improve access to health care
and increase funding for research
the first euros entered into circulation
20 years ago parliament marked the
anniversary with the european central
bank president christine lagarde
[Music]
you